Bienvenidos a esta entrevista de France
24 en español en la feria del libro de
Buenos Aires en su edición número 47 nos
acompaña un novelista ensayista
argentino que además estuvo a cargo del
discurso de apertura de esta feria del
libro Martín con muchas gracias Gracias
a ustedes por invitarme en la
presentación en el discurso de apertura
hablaste mucho mucho mucho de los
lectores
hay crisis de la lectura hoy en día se
puede decir que hay una crisis de la
lectura en tu opinión
o en realidad hay una crisis de la
lectura del libro Mira yo trato de no
incurrir en
perspectivas apocalípticas porque estoy
entrando claramente claramente y
fatídicamente en esa edad en la que se
empieza a pensar que todo era mejorantes
En todo caso una reflexión sí sobre el
estado de cosas que yo no lo haría pasar
necesariamente por el objeto libro como
dispositivo tradicional Aunque es el que
yo prefiero el que yo uso pero sí por
las condiciones generales de la de la
lectura la lectura requiere es una
escena que tiene que ver con cierto
grado de aislamiento cierto grado de
aislamiento e intento siempre digo no no
insisto no ser apocalíptico pero me
parece que en esta época nos estamos
viendo más
disponibles a la interrupción expuestos
a la interrupción más que nunca y no lo
pienso solamente en términos de la
lectura cualquier actividad que se te
ocurra La que quieras
Qué posibilidades hay de dedicarle a esa
actividad o incluso la inactividad a
sentarse y no hacer nada durante una
hora y media una hora y media ya casi no
es posible
mucha gente estuvo coqueteando estos
días y jugando con con estos grandes
modelos de lenguaje algunos dicen
Inteligencia artificial con los que uno
puede interactuar y generan respuestas
bastante articuladas o muy articuladas e
incluso
devuelven poemas textos de ficción y de
no ficción lo probaste
no sigo muy me pongo al día con las
tecnologías siempre pero siempre con un
delay en el caso de la Inteligencia
artificial
solo diría Esto me entusiasma todo lo
que promueva y estimule la lectura me
entusiasma todo lo que promueva y
estimule la escritura si es algo que
permitiría presentar un examen Según
dicen los que probaron todo esto que
podría incluso verse aprobado no con una
nota muy buena pero aprobado Entonces
estamos ante un dispositivo que eximiría
de leer y describir Y yo que tengo mi
profesión ligada leer y al escribir no
puedo entusiasmarme con eso ni aunque
quiera entiendo que hay un riesgo Por lo
pronto en el hecho de que cada uno de
nosotros como sujetos y como eso que
serán Llamar sujetos sociales tenemos
las condiciones de desarrollar una
cierta capacidad de comprensión de las
cosas de interpretación de las cosas y
en la medida en que nos vemos
empobrecidos en una capacidad nuestra
capacidad de comprensión de
interpretación de elaboración de
sentidos de intervención sobre ese mundo
nos empobrecemos el mundo en el que
estamos Me parece que es tan simple como
eso este año son se cumplen los 40 años
del regreso de la Democracia Argentina
en qué medida la ficción actual
está ayudándonos a pensar el estado
actual de la Democracia algunos ven
situaciones problemáticas siempre se ven
situaciones problemáticas en un ámbito
democrático este año hay mucha discusión
en torno a eso qué está haciendo la
ficción
escribiendo el discurso había pensado
que eventual deterioro del estado de
cosas es que lo hay pero en alguna
medida lo hay hay grandes ventajas pero
también desventajas
la vieja circunstancia del texto sacado
de contexto la frase sacada de contexto
ahora es la frase sacada de texto no de
contexto está Sacada del texto porque no
hay lectura del texto entonces pretendo
recuperar la especificidad de la
intensidad de la lectura de la
literatura en su posibilidad de
interpelación al espacio social y al
espacio político no estoy pensando en
una torre de Marfil no estoy pensando en
una burbuja aséptica y en ese sentido
claro encuentro que es decisivo lo que
la ficción puede hacer interpelando el
estado de cosas No necesariamente la
contemporaneidad
un poco con mi relación con la
tecnología que a veces se atrasa a veces
se adelanta porque a veces se adelanta a
veces encontramos en la literatura
signos de un de un desarrollo que la
sociedad iba a tener empíricamente
después
de manera que lo digo en estos términos
porque no No necesariamente
esta relación entre literatura y el
estado de cosas o entre las ficciones
argentinas y el desarrollo de estos 40
años de democracia en la Argentina lo
vamos a encontrar o lo tenemos que
buscar en esa clase de literatura más
orientada a una estética realista a un
propósito de representación de la
realidad social a una cierta función
testimonial o documental de la
literatura sino para mí preferentemente
en esa literatura que puede estar
desfasada
mediatizada Aparentemente alejada y que
gracias a esa separación o mediatización
está hablando del estado de cosas de un
modo más
justamente más mediado y por lo tanto no
sólo va a reproducir el estado de cosas
sino también va a plantearse dilemas y
alternativas frente al Estado de cosas
Martín con muchas gracias gracias a vos
y a ustedes gracias por acompañarnos en
esta entrevista de France 24